hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the mask reveals
disgusting face I hope they're not
talking about my face because beneath
this one isn't even handsomer version to
myself or so that's what I've been told
I haven't exactly tried to rip my own
face off but let's go into the game and
if you couldn't tell this is a horror
game and I've been trying to pump up the
bit of my lighting setup on my webcam
two years of bass since I've been
diagnosed with clinical depression since
then things didn't get any better my
friends tried to help me but nothing
worked
ultimately it seemed they stopped trying
I think they're disappointed in me
that's sad when all hope was gone I
started to feel like I'm a drag for
people around me I decided to spend some
time alone in an empty house outside the
town away from the problems away from
disappointed friends that's really
depressing about depressing of course
soon I realized that it was a bad idea
after a month spent in loneliness I lost
my mind completely my pains have grown
I've become paranoid but that's not the
worst thing that happened something
weird happened to this house okay then
today I found out that the house is
surrounded by a grid it appeared from
the nowhere I tried to get through it
but no luck I'm locked here but why why
indeed besides I feel like I'm not alone
here
I can hear strange sounds and I see
things oh god I really need to get out
indeed II do we do so this is a
pixelated style horror game and if
you've seen many of my other pixelated
style horror games no need to use a
computer
what is it not a good idea to use a
computer you've got games porn internet
porn everything you could possibly need
in life can use it there's no signal Oh
goodness well then time to venture out
into my own home why would I need to
know how to sprint this er early I
thought those lightbulbs were faces ah
so this is how this is gonna be now
don't let the looks deceive you I'm not
hungry I'm always hungry this just shows
the disconnect this game has from my
this is a mistake I'll go back inside
now thank you very much oh love the
sinister bass which reminds me of uh I
need a key to open it it's in my house
why would I need a [ __ ] a whatever don't
question the horror game just yet
markiplier Kyocera squeaky squeak is
somebody out there
I find it tiny box Timah batteries now
don't let this game's looks deceive you
as has been shown numerous times with
these pixelated horror games they can
pack quite a psychological punch when it
comes to the scares their reason for
being in here the bathroom had a crack
in the mirror my ugly face bro hit with
all of its ugly powers of ugliness I
keep swearing that is something up there
but no it's just a light bulb a rather
steep light bulb so I guess I need to
have to go outside hello
excuse me for trying to press my sexy
body up against the bars god dammit you
shut your trap hole alright so I get it
I'm not supposed to touch the gate and
my face you're ugly flying it up some
more
you guys don't think I have an ugly face
do you I have the best face but not
better than all of yours because you're
all beautiful people okay I guess I'm
supposed to go in there is anybody home
I don't know why I'm speaking such a
deep voice this entire game well god
it's just wound I don't like you for one
moment but either way uh what I was
trying to say said sometimes I get in
these moods where I oh it's dark I need
flashlights and batteries will I have
the batteries but I get in these moods
where I really like to see the
flexibility that my voice can provide
and I hope you guys will endure the
torture of my lyrical soft baseness why
is this blood tree not producing any
blood fruit I need some for my nightmare
factory to make nightmare lemonade and
to sell all to the nightmare kids of the
neighborhood who run around in pairs
they all twins they're all little girls
and they all dress in white and sing
creepy songs to me oh why can't I go
back out of nightmare town why did I
come here let's go upstairs and see
what's upstairs in the upstairs
Oh who broke my rhododendrons god I'm
gonna be so mad when I get up there I
forgive you
rhododendrons he my flowers are intact
I wonder if some other nightmarish
monstrosity awaits me what awaits me in
the darkness everybody okay let's find
out
naughty like I said I sometimes get in
these moods where I really want to
express myself I was about to say
talents but I don't have many of those
someone there
the clock is ticking but time means
nothing
oh I see so I need to find a combonation
is that a clue hello am I about to die
in seven days is anybody there
is anybody home no one good two one
three one all the clocks in the house of
stop working where since I've only seen
one clock so far I'm just going to guess
that that's a clue my old collection of
Records who has vinyl anymore these days
2 1 3 1 2 1 3 1
it's useless Gary you're stuck
completely stuck and you can do nothing
about it
all your life you've been walking down
the downward spiral and this place is
gonna be the end for you that's in my
left here okay
why alrighty then this is actually
giving me the heebie jeebies um I don't
know why but also I have the volume
turned up wait loud er than it needs to
be that's why my that game and that
surprised me so much jeez get out of my
life I thought those were windows
or not and there's some wushu whoosh the
TARDIS is making a flyby of my house to
see what sort of weird dimension I'm
trapped in this is the nightmare
dimension you might just want to move on
go someplace where Rose can follow good
blood my blood tree is working I'm so
glad I'm so happy I'll be able to sell
blood fruit after all oh this is going
to the bathroom isn't it you're going to
the bathroom
well that's fine now it's inside there
shall we everybody I'm sure it would be
delightful why is there a hole in my
floor that's exactly what I did in one
hello oh okay okay okay
why alrighty then just gonna okay I can
go back and forwards because that's
exactly what I would want to do when I
find a magical hole in the bottom of my
bathroom set a flashlight good great
well put batteries in it you do have
batteries on a minute but the men's a
thing why did you not why did you not
put batteries in the damn dirty thing
before I cave your head in
oh good I was wondering when the music
was gonna come back can I please put the
batteries in that thing
I put the screw and the Doudna so put
the batteries in the flashlight Oh God
well so I've got a bit of a draft in my
room there's a monster face some face
spider gonna come peering through my
window is anyone under my bed I don't
like this oh maybe I don't need to put
the batteries in
okay I apologize
what is it ladies and we caged Oh fun do
you like the feeling help us this s very
much the dead Gary and soon you'll
realize it - okay great cool I think I'm
starting to realize it I think you're a
bit of a dick I'm just gonna excuse that
for now and I'm gonna continue on my way
to the basement because I make poor
choices in my life and I decided that
going into dark dirty places there is
ideal for my recreational habits you'll
miss a minute did I go this way oh no I
went the long way before let's go down
oh good ray
basement of nightmares let me just check
that off my bucket list of horror games
basement of nightmares one flashlight
seemingly dead already and in a
nightmare limbo land and I'm probably
down here about to me Mert alized the
creatures in my mind I don't remember
the cellar being so huge that's what she
said to me after I locked her down there
early what was that is that a Spidey web
in my follow this water good good I'm
glad that that's just that I was worried
that it was going to be something more
sinister like what lies beneath my
nightmares
this is where I store my nightmare fruit
this is where all his children would
come to pay partay who was a delicious
what is that
surly monster God my my shoulders are up
near my eyebrows right now
that's our tents I am Oh Grob ah I
needed this for something
I think the Prague
the bag well that's good though I can
only go one way I'm sure this book and
lively why I don't like you I don't like
you at all I want to go home can you
please just let me oh that is fun all
this just fun I like it but I don't like
it I don't like it at all
oh god I'm burning a circle okay
I apologize sounds gonna father
something better pop out at me after all
this bull after all the bull honky that
your pile on top of my plate heaven okay
is my face still beautiful am i ugly yet
is my face disgusting has it been
revealed does everyone know that I'm
actually handsome Jack oh good I can go
home gray right I made it out alive kind
of as I am already dead oh I think I
know how this game is gonna end
oh god another pit of despair what is
with those okay cuz that's normal to be
at the bottom of a shed is this gonna be
like finger bones I hope this place will
lead me to an exit why do you not know
what this place is isn't the truth
already revealed to you young man I can
feel the soil falling over my head and
as I climb into an empty bed I know it's
over I don't know where else I can go I
know where else didn't go to hell and
back unless it was me that wrote that
and go to heaven place or some
equivalent
why do I feel okay this is good why do I
feel like I'm being led into a pit of
despair well let's go down let's go down
the only Road that I've ever known the
odd thing is I haven't seen anything
that would cause me to actually feel
alright let's find out what it is
who's there who's knock knock knocking
on my door I don't want any hello know
how good who's banging will be banging
I'm I got a crowbar
I really don't want to open that door
well me clicking on it clearly indicated
my desire to open it fine if you're
going to be a big baby a big bubble
blowing baby then okay oh that's not
good you came back what did something
happen is someone there
hello well the orchestra arrived
now cue the monster hello oh oh good my
blood flu has my blood flute fruit has
sprouted legs and began walking oh good
well whatever was trapped down here is
now going to be stalking me as I walk in
perpetuity to my death so now that I
have elcio I can go right here oh I'm in
land further into death surely I will be
walking to safety at some point hmm
why couldn't I have just stayed in my
bed Oh tiny box Tim is that you hey is
that oh my god could it be that I know
if it actually is I don't want to raise
hope that it may or may not be what it's
all god I thought that was a thing in
the darkness it's silhouette it was not
very happy am I supposed to take you
with me
are you tiny box Tim no I'm little
little great Larry I don't know I don't
know you're not you're not very cool
little crate Larry I don't think that
you can help me very much but I'm gonna
carry you with me anyway because you
make me feel safe okay okay that turned
off that so maybe I could why is there a
phone oh wise phone
this doesn't make any sense yes oh
really oh you're going to kill me don't
hang up yet I was having such a lovely
conversation with you glad I answered
that what a lovely friend wait a minute
this is slightly different than it was
before wait a minute there's another box
over there why do I need you
what are you all God wait a minute
what now there's lots of boxes I spotted
three oh I see okay it's tiny box two
Tim's friends that all need to go to
hell and die no no I never do that my
little biscuit but I just might smash
your heads open and not be nicely I'm
not doing too well in this game this
game has really given me the creeps more
than any other like it's the weird thing
about these pixelated style horror games
something about losing myself like
lowering my expectations of the graphics
when I go into this gum when I go into
these games and sometimes you know they
do suffer from the graphical
capabilities of game but when you go
into it with the understanding that
those are the limitations of this
particular game it can lead to to become
more immersed in it than ever before
it's this weird thing where you know
it's like whatever you want to call it
the gaming transfer or whatever have you
just this um intangible property for a
game to make you fall into the world and
that is like portrayed a lot more in
terms of horror games as opposed to many
of the other genres but something about
horror games and something about these
pixelated sell horror games nonetheless
really really make me
I do not like it I do not like it at all
so I need to go back I need to find one
more box
maybe down this hallway that I haven't
gone down yet maybe that would be clue
that's ok everybody know how could you
not go towards me any further okay all
right
the double finger defense has never ever
failed me in the past why would it now
let's wait a minute was there a message
on one of these filing cabinet walls
anything pertinent for me to read that
my audience would create a appreciate
I've never been so tense playing a game
in my entire life I hope you guys don't
mind okay
and we're good okay all game saved even
good I thought that this never mind
the nightmares are here again okay I
didn't even know that I could save why
can I save I can't go in these doors
this is gonna be fun this is gonna end
with Sunshine's rainbows Josh
I'm running
am i winning
don't know if I'm winning
oh good that's why it saved my game oh
there's no door back there I just walked
through a crack in the wall has anybody
read this really creepy comic from Japan
the Enigma of something-something fault
with God those oh it's gun No
oh I had a feeling is my pistol what's
it doing in here
Oh No Oh God why did you come in here
you haven't achieved anything by this oh
boy there's no escape you're stuck here
forever and never ending pain will make
you insane but you can make it stop the
choice is yours
oh man I had a feeling oh god no no I
will resist I don't want to die here
exactly good do you honestly think you
can save yourself yes yes I do
time to take off the masks masks Oh
sanity is 80 okay why do I shoot you
LEM but I get you laughs yeah no I don't
right yeah oh boy okay this is not cool
bruh
okay got you in the face I don't care if
I've got a disgusting face under the
mask I Will Survive I will survive as
long as I know how to love I'm sure I'll
stay alive that's right that's right you
douche I can't exactly do the double
finger defense right now but you will
suck 10 bullets that is not your ugly
face before you get me are you you're
way too close to me friend
way to go do you argue me that's right
that's right that's right
who's who now okay no no no no yeah did
I get you
all right so hard to hedge a prayer
today win did did I get him yeah I can
oh it's all over I finally managed to
defeat my own fears cleaning up my mind
all this time the grid existed only in
my head my personal demons locked me up
here but I won and now I'm free oh sorry
I forgot that I had clicked there I've
come back to the house and found
something what wasn't there before
a letter from my friends they're not
disappointed in me they asked me to come
back the kind words finally reminded me
that I'm not alone and this still hope
fully calm I step out of the house we're
just a few hours ago I was suffering my
worst nightmare yet finally I'm coming
back and this time I will find the
solution I'm coming home
by Zykov Eddie okay it's really strange
because I guess not strange is the right
word but these horror games often touch
on really sensitive topics like
depression and suicide and just some
really disgusting parts of humanity and
not necessarily disgusting but really
dark parts of our own being and and I
guess that's what is accompanied by fear
a lot it's these other topics that a lot
of people don't like to talk about but
depression is a very very big topic in
if you're suffering from depression and
I know and it's really awesome because
not depression mind you but it's awesome
because I get a lot of messages and I
still read a lot all that I can I get so
many these days but people telling me
that my videos and everything that I do
helps them cope with the depression that
they have and there may not be a
surefire cure it's something that a lot
of people have to live with their entire
life but the knowledge that I or my
videos are me being a [ __ ] on the
internet can help in any way is really
great it's a great feeling to me and I'm
glad that I can help but if you're
suffering from depression and you don't
know what you can do to help like
there's always another way you know
suicide is not the answer it never will
be and in the end it's going to be a
decision that you have to make but
understand that there is always going to
be help out there for you you know there
going to be people that are willing to
help even though you may feel like
you're trapped in a bubble or in a cage
like this guy obviously this guy has
some experience with depression himself
even though it may feel like you're
trapped there's always another way and I
would adamantly recommend that if you
feel trapped or if you've ever
considered you know harming yourself in
any way please don't like seriously
there is any other option there are so
many options and there are so many
outlets
just reach out to this the people in
this community alone you can talk with
people who have dealt with this very
same thing you're not alone in anything
that you've done
so even though these horror games do
touch on sensitive topics and I do try
to make them entertaining and fun to
watch for you guys understand that they
they're real topics you know they're
things that people deal with all the
time and I hope that you guys understand
that I don't want you guys to feel like
you've been abandoned in any way you
guys are not alone especially those who
are in the darkest parts of their life
right now I want you to know that I do
these videos for you and I'm glad that I
can help in any way I may just be one
guy but this community is big it is
awesome and there are people willing to
help so talk with each other guys anyone
I've dragged on a bit long this game was
great I really enjoyed this it was
thoroughly creepy and I didn't even see
a single a single monster type thing
until the very end and that was super
cool well done man thank you everybody
who helped out and thank you everybody
for watching check the description
there's a whole bunch of other pixelated
style games that I've played in the past
they're all worth seeing check them out
for yourself thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
where is he where is it he's gonna come
back hey girl can I
where I got me right in front of me that
is I need the hallways Oh